peu
non
[Musique]
il
une assemblée parlementaire les 501
général en uniforme napoléon bonaparte
et lin le général est au milieu des
députés de l'autre elle est députée
entoure ce général le bouscule de
partout le bourg de coups de poing la
jury l'insultent le traite des mots les
plus effrayants et le général a peur et
le général des failles il général
s'évanouit et il faut que les grenadiers
qui l'entourent l'emportent
il a fuit et il a eu peur
cela c'est l'épisode dominant du coup
d'état du 18 brumaire qui s'est
d'ailleurs passer le lendemain le 19
brute mais on ne sait pas très bien
pourquoi on parle du coup d'état du 18
brumaire et il faut se demander pourquoi
nous allons parler ce soir du 18
brumaire du 19 points mais est bien
parce qu'il s'agit d'une crise qui a eu
pour la france des conséquences énormes
immense et puis parce que c'est un drame
une tragédie où toutes les unités sont
respectés l'unité d'action de temps de
lieu et puis enfin parce que dans une
crise comme celle là justement l'homme
l'homme qui nous intéresse ce qui nous
intéressera toujours cet homme là
apparaît dans toute sa nudité et disons
le il apparaît fascinant alors tout
commence quelques semaines plus tôt peu
de temps avant nous sommes le 9 novembre
et la faire on peut dire qu'elle
commence le 9 octobre juste un mois
avant le 9 octobre 1999 à bateaux le
nuire on jette l'ancré dans le port de
saint raphaël est un homme en descend
c'est le général balle
bonaparte bonaparte si l'ambition il a
commencé à ressentir après ses premières
victoires d'italie l'a confié d'ailleurs
et puis ensuite il a voulu aller porter
un coup décisif en egypte et atteindre
la puissance anglaise en fait et sans
d'ailleurs qu'il l'ait prémédité
semble-t-il il a écrit là à sa légende
bien mieux qu'auparavant bien mieux
qu'ailleurs et il est devenu lorsque les
bulletins de victoire sont arrivés
d'orient et ont été égrénés dans la
presse française et bien il est devenu
le héros par excellence le héros
national et cela il en a eu la
prescience
et quand les nouvelles du directoire
sont arrivés quand elles se sont
révélées fasher
désespérant et bien d'un seul coup il a
décidé de partir partir
et oui partir pour prendre le pouvoir il
ya préméditation la certaine il ya les
confidences de bonaparte en égypte à
menou voilà parts lui a dit je vais
rentrer je vais chasser les avocats je
vais quand le gouvernement de la france
alors oui les parties d'abandonner son
arme et oui c'est vrai le fait est là
le voyage a duré 47 jours et maintenant
il est à fréjus à saint raphaël à fréjus
alors bien sûr il ya la quarantaine
c'est à dire que théoriquement des gens
qui arrivent d'un voyage lointain
surtout d'orient doivent rester en
observation 40 jours pour savoir s'il
n'apporte pas la peste
alors bien sûr il n'y a pas de
quarantaine pour mona pas et le voilà
déjà qui prend la route
d'aix-en-provence
et puis celle de marseille à paris le
voile à avignon et avignon c'est sous
les fenêtres de son hôtel une foule
immense
des acclamations sans fin et la voiture
qui repart et alors il se passe un
phénomène extraordinaire c'est que
part et d'autre de la grand route et
bien les paysans qui sont dans les
champs ou bien les vignerons qui sont
dans les vignes à bandol leur travail
pour venir acclamer bonaparte à lyon à
lyon il semble que toute la ville
l'acclament on tire des feux d'artifice
ont on illumine la ville est pavoisée de
drapeaux les gens dansent dans les rues
et même on joue une pièce de
circonstance le soir au théâtre pour lui
les acteurs ne savent même pas leur rôle
ils n'ont pas eu le temps de l'apprendre
il le bat fouillis mais enfin le fait
est là la france la classe et pourquoi
et bien parce que les français sont
fatigués les français sont l'ars
ils ne veulent plus de ce qu'ils ont ils
veulent autre chose
vous savez l'image que nous avons du
directoire elle est un petit peu
folklorique pour nous le directoire
c'est ce ballet ce sont ces fêtes
somptueuses cordone autour du bo barras
les merveilleuses qu'elle s'appelle
madame tallien madame hamelin ou même
joséphine de beauharnais
et oui nous imaginons toujours autour de
barras cette fête qui s'ordonne c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya eu des jouisseurs sous
le directoire
c'est vrai tout cela qu'il y a eu des
fêtes il y à une aj otages qu il y a eu
une immense bacchanales mais ça n'est
que le rideau superficielle qui entoure
la vérité et la vérité c'est autre chose
la vérité c'est la france qui est à bout
bien sûr il n'ya plus de sang qui coule
comme autrefois mais quoique on pourrait
dire bien des choses de la guillotine
sèche des îles seychelles et de cayenne
mais on en n'est plus loin que la peur
du sang on en est au désespoir ce pays
qu'est ce que c'est
et bien c'est au sommet des
révolutionnaires nantis qui ont obtenu
ce qu'il voulait c'est à dire pour eux
le pouvoir et par le pouvoir la fortune
autour du directeur barras je cite
toujours son nom mais il incarne cette
société bien c'est la corruption
généralisée barras vie avec des traitant
avec des financiers avec des banquiers
louche il fait il brasse comme il dit
des affaires et puis c'est
révolutionnaire lentilles qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent c'est garder le pouvoir à
tout prix alors il n'est plus question
de principe
la république on cite son nom mais on
l'a oublié alors quand il y à une
pression vers la droite
eh bien on fait un coup d'état vers la
droite et puis quand il nya une pression
vers la gauche ont fait un coup d'état
vers la gauche et on jugule ces
oppositions ont fait taire les gêneurs à
coude et à généraliser et répété et puis
si nous parcourons cette france qu'est
ce que nous découvrons nous découvrons
dans plusieurs régions du pays des zones
d'insécurité nous découvrons la terreur
blanche des brigands qui occupent vu des
provinces qui rançonnent les voyageurs
qui attaquent les voitures public et on
ne peut pas on n'a pas la force de venir
à bout de ces brigands et puis les
routes
qu'est ce que c'est que les routes
étaient bien les routes ce sont des
fondrières on les a pas entretenu depuis
des années les prisons les prisons sont
des cloaques d'ailleurs on sent les
vagues comme on veut les hôpitaux sont
désespérants les enfants assistés qu'on
les appelle des enfants de la république
meurent par milliers parce qu'on n'a pas
d'argent pour les nourrir les porcs sont
embourbés marseille est un cimetière de
bateaux à bordeaux on a plus de lumière
pour allumer les lanternes la nuit le
havre est un cimetière lui aussi
alors les gens voient cela les gens
vivent cela ils voient cette corruption
ils voient que l'argent
le peu d'argent qu'on récolte parce que
les impôts on n'est même pas capable de
les faire rentrer et bien c'est pour
enrichir certains alors que les soldes
avant pieds nus avec des souliers en
carton et reçoivent d'innommables
marchandises et te dire que dire des
finances entre 1991 et 1997 l'assignât
est passé de 3000 à 1 celui qui avait
3000 francs n'a plus qu'un franc la
dévaluation a atteint 99,96 % c'est la
ruine de tous et même en 1797
on a voulu réduire des deux tiers les
rangs de ceux qui avaient encore
quelques rangs et on appelait ça c'est
de l'humour le tiers consolider et même
en 99 au moment où bonaparte revient on
le paye même plus et rentre là on donne
aux malheureux rentiers des bons d'arrêt
rage commandés et voilà cette france qui
se révèle devant bonaparte qui a la
conscience lorsqu'il roule de marseille
à paris d'aix-en-provence à paris de
fréjus à paris qui a tous conscience que
ça ne peut pas durer et surtout que les
français veulent que ça ne dure pas il
faut lire d'hambourg yens il faut lire
dans bruyen qui étaient là dans la
voiture jusqu'à paris le signe qui se
lisait sur le visage de bonaparte de
l'incrédulité d'abord de la stupéfaction
et peu à peu la conviction qui n'est la
france matin or cet homme qui roule vers
paris est également un homme torturé un
homme désespéré un homme qui souffre
pourquoi
et bien parce que l'egypte il a su on le
lui a écrit ses frères le lui ont dit il
est trempé
celui que la france traite comme un
héros n'est qu'un mari trompé et celles
qui la trompe et c'est la charmante
l'adorable joséphine ça a commencé très
tôt il était à peine marié il était
parti pour l'italie où barras l'avait
fait nommer il a supplié de la rejoindre
et il lui écrivait des lettres admirable
et elle elle restait à paris parce qu'il
y avait quelqu'un d'autre il s'appelait
hippolyte charles c'était un petit
capitaine il n'était pas l' quand il
mesure 1 mètre 50 n'ont failli lui
plaisait fils adoré les calembours alors
ça l'amusé plus que son mari et pendant
la campagne d'égypte bien la liaison a
continué mais là elle était folle elle
s'est montrée à tous en compagnie de
charles elle s'est affichée elle était
folle de et toute la famille bonaparte
l'a vu avec charles la famille bonaparte
a juré la perte de josé fait et c'est ce
qu'il a appris en egypte est là dans
cette voiture alors qu'on l'appela mhz
alors que les populations arrivent alors
que les milliers des dizaines de
milliers de français viennent sur le
long des routes pour crier vive
bonaparte bien lui il pense à sa femme
il pense cette femme dont il veut
divorcer car il en est sûr il divorcera
et quand ils arrivent le 16 octobre à
paris ils courent rue de la victoire qui
est le nouveau nom de la rue chanteraine
et c'est là que s'élèvent sa maison
cette charmante maison où il a été
heureux avec joséphine et là il trouve
la maison vide
et oui parce que joséphine a appris le
retour de bonaparte et là elle s'est
affolée elle avait été folle mais elle
s'affole essais libres mais qu'est ce
que j'ai fait il ne pardonnera jamais et
tout à coup elle veut plus le perdre et
c'est ça qui est curieux peut-être qu'on
prend tel ce que représente son mari ce
dont peut-être elle n'a jamais jusque là
essayez de comprendre la réalité alors
elle s'élance en voiture elle veut aller
au devant de lui elles veulent se jeter
dans ses bras éviter que d'autres la
voient 20 le voit avant elle
malheureusement elle prend la route de
bourgogne et bonaparte a pris la route
du bourbonnais et c'est pourquoi il
trouve la maison vide et le lendemain 17
octobre
il fait réunir toutes les affaires de
joséphine et dieu sait si elle a des
robes et dieu sait si elle a des chalets
dieu sait s'il a des chapeaux et des
chaussures et tout ça il en remplit en
fait remplir des mallettes toutes les
affaires de joséphine sont portés chez
le convient quand elle se présentera
qu'elle n'entre pas sur tout et qu'elle
parte avec ce qui lui appartient et le
18 elle arrive hors d'elle
les frères eux ont vu bonaparte avant
tel et les frères ont fait le procès de
joseph y et l'arrivée passe outre à
l'interdît elle monte au premier étage c
la nuit et là elle se heurte à une porte
fermée à clé c'est la porte de leurs
champs elle sait qu'il est là derrière
la porte elle frappe
elle se meurtri les points sur le bois
de la porte
elle appelle bonaparte elle l'a toujours
appelé bonaparte et pas par son prénom
bonaparte il répond pas
alors elle pleure elle sanglote et elle
pleure elle criel frappé lui les
derrières meurtri déchirer alors elle
appelle ses enfants hortense et eugène
ils arrivent ils pleurent avec elle et
ça dure des heures imaginer cela des
heures et enfin il ouvre la pente
elle tombe dans ses bras
ils l'emmènent elle a gagné le lendemain
matin quand les frères arriveront ils
trouveront pas la parte au lit avec
joséphine ça évite des explications il
n'oubliera jamais mais il pardonne en
est en tout cas maintenant il a l'esprit
libre l'esprit libre pour ce qu'il est
venu faire à paris cinq directeurs à la
tête du directoire
goyer le président bharrat ce moulin
rouge est du coc et sieyès ou peux pas
dire qui gouverne la france
disons seulement qu'ils administrent de
désordre et pourtant ces gens là ne sont
pas aveugles devant la réalité savent
très bien que ça ne peut pas durer et
notamment l'un d'entre eux sieyès et
particulièrement lucide et depuis un
long moment il pense à mettre fin à ce
directoire rejeté par les français
alors pourquoi et bien parce que il est
attaché à la république c'est justement
pour préserver la république qu'il veut
mettre fin au directoire et donner à la
france une nouvelle constitution une
constitution qu'il porte en lui même
depuis fort longtemps et puis aussi il a
eu vent des tractations encore des
tractations louche que hub arras avec le
prétendant louis xviii et ne veut pas de
la mollarchie 6
alors il cherche
il sait très bien qu'il ne peut pas
faire un coup d'état tout seul et lui
faut une épée il dit il faut une tête et
une épée la tête il l'a c'est la sienne
mais les pays où la prendra t c'est un
curieux personnage ce seuil est ce au
début de la révolution
c'était la bcs il a jeté la soutane aux
orties et surtout il a publié cette
brochure célèbre vous savez qu est ce
que le clip tiers état
et puis le passé à travers cette
révolution entourée de mystère il se
tait il a eu l'art de faire savoir qu'il
possédait le secret de la constitution
idéal mais ne veut pas livrer la garde
pour des temps meilleurs
alors ça intéresse tout le monde et des
10 et 189 mirabeau s'écrie le silence de
monsieur sieyès est une calamité
publique et ce silence poursuit pendant
la révolution et danseurs mais pour une
phrase pour un mot quand il vote la mort
de louis saez il dit seulement de son
air glacé la mort sans phrase quand il
aura traversé la terreur qu'on lui dira
qu'avez vous fait pendant la terreur il
répondra j'ai vécu un autre jour le mot
est moins connu on était passé plusieurs
fois à l'ordre du jour il se penche vers
son voisin il dit quand passera ton au
jour de l'ordre qu'un témoin
contemporain dit une chose joly à propos
de sieyès il dit que en disant bonjour
il semblait faire une confidence ça le
résume bien
alors oui la tête et l'épée ou la
prendre les pays il a pensé à jour dans
ça n'a pas marché la pensée à joubert
mais joubert a été tué en italie la
pensée à morrow morrow était à peu près
d'accord
et puis quand en aparté barque et à
fréjus
moreau est venu trouver sieyès et lui a
dit voilà votre homme il fera le coup
d'état mieux que moi et pourtant je n'ai
pas bon à part ça n'est pas si yes que
bonaparte a abordé en arrivant à paris
le connais pas c'est plutôt barras qu'il
est allé voir parce qu'il le connaît lui
bien c'est barras ne l'oublions pas
qu'il a fait nommer commandant de
l'armée d'italie c'est la dot qu'il a
reçus pour son mariage avec joséphine
elle même ancienne maîtresse de barrage
il a trouvé un barras sceptiques revenu
de tout comprenant qu'en effet on était
à l'agonie et envisageant un changement
de constitution et
au long de plusieurs conversations il a
même esquissé ce qu'il pensait de ce
changement de constitution
pourquoi pas une présidence de la
république
et puis il a regardé dans la partie il
ya dix ou il faudrait un président de la
république que je pense à un militaire
et vous imaginez le regard de bonaparte
pendant ce temps là le regard sur barras
et barras a ajouté j'ai pensé au général
et douville et vous imaginez encore le
regard de bonnes à porte et le mépris
absolu qu'est ce que c'est que ce jeu
que juhasz désormais barras s'est perdu
dans l'esprit de bonaparte d'autant plus
que barras a le mauvais goût de répéter
tout le temps que bonaparte me dois tous
les saints agace prodigieusement valable
alors qu'ils abordaient gohier le
président du directoire oui parce que
moulins et roger ducos bien il n'y pense
même pas ils sont des personnages falots
alors gohier peut-être le président
parce que goyer est un ami de sa femme
c'est un homme plus très jeune c'est un
homme qui a surtout eu beaucoup d'
aventure galante dans sa vie dont il a
tenu une comptabilité absolument
extraordinaire et il était amoureux je
défie nos amoureux transis mais en fait
c'est ça c'est comme ça alors pourquoi
pas les voir gagner alors il va voir
goyer et lui laissant entendre qu'ils
n'entreraient volontiers dans le
directoire mais oui lui goyer j'en
serais ravi mais enfin général pensez-y
la constitution est formel il faut avoir
40 ans pour être directeur vous avez 30
ans oui parce qu'il a 30 ans et
bonaparte qui réagit immédiatement vous
attachez à la lettre de la constitution
président oui général président il ya
des lettres qui tue est décidément voilà
gohier rayé des papiers de bonaparte et
oui il faudra tout de même qu'il
rencontre sieyès et pourtant aucun des
deux hommes ne veut faire le premier pas
c'est lucien lucien bonaparte le frère
qui va les réunir enfin chez lui rue
vert
les voilà face à face keyes vol à part
et quand ils se voient ils s'embrassent
ils se donnent l'accolade c'est le style
du temps et bonaparte va au fait
le moment est venu où en sont les
mesures que vous avez pris alors sieyès
veut commencé à exposer sa constitution
en sait quelque chose de magnifique sa
constitution c'est une chose en pyramide
alors tout à fait au sommet il ya le
grand électeur lecomte électeurs bien
entendu dans son esprit c'est lui alors
il loge au palais de versailles touche 6
millions par an et il nomme tout le
monde c'est lui qui nomme me nomme un
concile de la paix un consul de la
guerre alors peut-être bien que pour le
consulat de la guerre on prendra
bonaparte s'asseyait ce que veut bien
enfin il n'a pas le temps de commencer à
raconter sa constitution il s'est depuis
si longtemps que maintenant il a envie
de parler bien on lui reproche de parler
c'est bonaparte qui lui coupe la parole
je sais cela citoyens sieyès yeux c'est
sa part mon frère mais ne croyez pas que
vous puissiez imposer une constitution
en français et voilà parts développe à
son tour son projet il faut transpirer
le conseil des anciens et le conseil des
cinq sens c'est-à-dire les deux
assemblées législatives et transféré à
saint cloud obtenir d'eux qu'ils nomment
un gouvernement provisoire des consuls
puisque si yes tient au mot consul et
une commission législative qui préparera
la constitution et c'est cela qu'on
proposera aux français qui se
prononceront si liesse et déconcerté ce
n'est pas du tout ce qu'il avait prévu
voilà que ce petit général ce jeune
homme ce freluquet lui dicte sa conduite
mais il perd donc l'initiative widi
bonaparte d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord moi je ne marche pas mais bon à
part ça et voilà si elle y est restée
tout mélancolique avec lucien bonaparte
qui dit il manoeuvre comme sur le champ
de bataille mais je ne puis pas me
passer de lui
les premiers pas sont fait les premiers
pas sont faits et le processus est
amorcé alors désormais sieyès va prendre
des contacts va prendre des contacts
parmi ses amis qu'il a aux anciens et
obtenir que si on réunit les anciens et
bien ils votent le transfert à saint
cloud pendant ce temps là par s'occupe
des militaires alors ria quelques
militaires qui sont des inconditionnels
il est sur deux lits à sebastiani il ya
leclerc ya mur alors on n'en parle même
pas il les voit aussitôt ils sont
disponibles
le plus dur c'est lefebvre le faire
parce que lefebvre c'est un dur à cuire
et on le dit attaché aux institutions
républicaines
alors voilà parts convoque lefebvre qui
arrive et il ne t'a jeunes mon appart à
l'art de cajoler les gens il a eu un
sabre son côté il le tire dit général
voilà le sabre que je portais au kram et
je vous en fais donc en preuve de mon
estime et de ma confiance voilà le vieux
dur à cuire qui est bouleversée qui d'un
seul coup mais son coeur tout droit
dehors et dit bien ah oui jetons les
avocats dans la rivière celui-là
marchera alors bernadotte bernadotte
c'est plus difficile
bernadotte c'est un homme qui a des
ambitions personnelles il n'a pas vu
d'un bon oeil voit l'appart revenir car
le travail que va faire bonaparte il
était tout prêt à le faire lui-même
alors une ne s'engage pas il restera
toujours en dehors de la main il ya un
civil aussi dont bonaparte va se charger
ses fous chez le ministre de la police
d'abord il la méprise et pour lui
c'était un comique qui s'occupe
d'affaires peu reluisante mais real son
conseiller lui ali attention foucher
c'est l'homme important
c'est l'homme capital si foucher contre
vous vous échouerez alors il a fait
venir foucher il a été classé par
l'apparence de fouché par ses cheveux
roux c'est sourcil et c6 incolore ces
taches de sang qu'il a dans les yeux
et puis quand ils ont entendu parler il
a senti l'intelligence et la senti que
c'était quelque avec qu'il fallait
compter il a fait ce qu'il fallait et à
la fin d'entretien foucher était conquis
ont conquis attention ils étaient prêts
à ne rien faire contre on n'a pas messi
la faire tourner mal 100g bien que
foucher avait prévu une position de
repli mais enfin on ne l'avait pas
contre lui
on n'avait pas de comptes reçoit et
c'est ça qui était d'abord le 15
brumaire le 15 brumaire grand banquet à
l'église saint sulpice qui est
transformé en temple de la république ou
quelque chose comme ça 750 invités en
l'honneur de bonaparte et de moro alors
on s'ennuie beaucoup il fait très froid
d'abord alors le froid rend l'atmosphère
glaciale on mange rapidement par la
peine et puis très vite bonaparte se
lève de table rejoint ci s est il à
bordeaux alors où en êtes vous tout est
prêt général nous font la sphère le 17
mai 17 rien ne se passe contretemps mais
le 18 c'est le jour où tout doit
démarrer
alors voilà parti à jouer avec une
finesse assez étonnant parce que pour
éviter que gohier n'intervienne dans le
saint des du directoire parmi les cinq
directeurs on dispose de sieyès et de
roger ducos et 10 barras on ne sait pas
mais on verra où là on ne sait pas mais
gohier attention c'est le président du
directoire alors voilà par là accepté
une invitation à dîner pour le 18 comme
ça goyer ne se méfiera pas mêmes il a
invité gohier
et sa femme à prendre le petit déjeuner
avec lui et joséphine pour le 18
brumaire à 8 heures du man pour barras
il lui a fait dire qu'il viendrait le
voir secrètement dans la nuit du 17 au
18 et bien entendu n'y va pas c'est
bourienne give bourienne le secrétaire
et bruyen qui arrive au luxembourg chez
barras et qui lui dit le général
bonaparte à de la migraine il viendra
demain débarrasse tous tristes qui lit
non il viendra pas tout est fini et
pourtant il me doit taux reviennent
revient rue de la victoire dans la nuit
fait son rapport à bonaparte qui
s'amusent et voilà partis dit à demain
bruyen à 7 heures et le lendemain 18
brumaire à 7 heures du matin justement
le conseil des anciens se réunit et dans
l'ancienne salle de la convention aux
tuileries
pourquoi conseil des anciens bien parce
qu il y a deux chambres comme nous avons
deux chambres alors si vous voulez le
sénat notre sénat c'est le conseil des
anciens et notre assemblée nationale
et bien c'est le conseil des 500 jeudi
500 parce que certains une tradition
s'est établie de dire 500 mais pourquoi
dure cinq cent dix ans un sens c'est
plus simple alors dans la nuit on
envoyait des messages et partout les
hestayres fait qu'ils ont convoqué les
membres des anciens pour la réunion qui
aura lieu à 7 heures du matin le 18
jeudi convoquer les députés
attention pas tous les députés pas tous
les anciens parce que ceux dont on pense
qu'ils pourraient être opposant et bien
cela on a oublié le convoquer les
estafettes comme par hasard ont perdu
les convocations
enfin il ya là une sorte masse d'anciens
le 18 brumaire à 7h du matin et on ne
sait pas ce
pourquoi on est là en fait lamaneurs
c'est celle qu'avait prescrite bona park
constitutionnellement les anciens à eux
seuls ont le droit de voter un décret
qui peut ordonner le transfert des deux
assemblées dans un autre lieu que paris
et c'est ce qu'on va demander aux
anciens pour se prononcer pour que les
anciens et les 500 soit transféré à
saint cloud et ses députés sont là ne
savent pas pourquoi ils sont là pourquoi
si tôt 7 heures du matin pour kouassi
hâtivement est aussi tout à l'ancien
camp et monte à la tribune
pensez bien tout ça me témine manigancé
avec cs et caen et dénonce un complot
terrible complot les brigands sont là
ils entourent les assemblées
parlementaires le directoire le régime
est en danger il faut parer à ces périls
qui assaillent de toutes parts la règle
c'est épouvantable a déjà parlé beaucoup
de brigands vous savez depuis les débuts
de la révolution et là ça dépasse tout
le tableau que fait corner est
épouvantable fidèles sont attribués est
alors un second renier ou ça a été
manigancé monte à la tribune et d'écouté
je viens d'apprendre avec terreur ce que
vient de dire mon collègue alors il faut
prendre des mesures immédiates pour se
couper des brigands qui sont dans paris
nous savons ce que c'est des faubourgs
qui vont se lever et bien pour se couper
des brigands qui t'ont paris je propos
le transfert pour demain des deux
assemblées a simple alors tout le monde
est là silencieux étonné stupéfie y est
deux ou trois membres qui lisent mes
enfants pourraient peut-être tout dire
ce que c'est que ce complot ne dit qu'un
complot ne donne pas de nom ne dira est
raté et vous disent les autres nous
sommes en danger
et comme un seul homme les anciens vote
le transfert à saint cloud à la
l'opération qui a réussi et aussi tools
réunion a duré une heure à peu près un
huissier dépêché à bonaparte rue de la
victoire
pour les porter la nouvelle car les
anciens ont en même temps décrété c'est
ce qui était prévu par les conjurés pas
le faux complots le vrai ce qui était
prévu c'était de nommer vol à part
commandant de la force armée pour
protéger les deux conseils législatifs
des prions justement whisky brigands il
y avait essayé bonaparte est nommé et on
va le lui annoncer lui s'il monte à
cheval et cours rue de la victoire et
line à sa stupeur il trouve la rue de la
victoire noire de monde il ya là des
militaires presque seulement des
militaires et puis dans la petite
impasse qu'il juin la rue de la victoire
à la maison de la rue chanteraine il y a
également beaucoup de monde il y a des
gens à cheval il ya des gens à pied des
officiers des généraux tout ça est en
uniforme et alors le jardin le jardin
grouille de monde la maison on ne
pourrait plus faire entrer personne être
star s'est depuis lors ce sont les gens
qui sont venus parce qu'ils savent et
parce que bonaparte a fait appel à eux
et que bonaparte a besoin d'eux et ils
sont là ils ont répondu présent mais
voilà il est huit heures du matin voilà
madame gaulier qui arrive elle est tout
seul parce que son mari c'est quand même
un petit peu mais fier au dernier moment
elle n'est pas venue déjeuner il
envoyait sa femme
alors on entoure sa femme voilà par
joséphine me disent ils font mille grâce
pourquoi votre mari n'était pas là parce
qu'il n'a pas pu venir armés de
écrivez-lui devenir bien sûr sigoyer
venait là il serait pratiquement
prisonniers mais s'ils envoyaient lui un
mot de plus de venir ce sera bien mieux
et madame on voyait qui a tout compris
écrit un petit mot à son mari dans
lequel elle lui dit surtout ne vient pas
et on cache est le petit mot et c'est un
messager du général bonaparte qui va
porter à goyer ce billet par lequel
boyer prévenu surtout de ne pas arriver
au ray de la victoire le huissier devant
bonaparte
il salue car il est un peu un précurseur
le sauveur de la patrie est
immédiatement bel appartement à cheval
suivi par un énorme état-major
d'officiers de jeunes héros est tout ce
monde s'en va dans les tuileries où la
force armée entre temps a été réunie et
bonaparte va déjà installé la force
armée dans le jardin des tuileries
devant l'assemblée des anciens l'antre
il est 10 heures maintenant
il entre chez les anciens
et là il prête serment à la constitution
disons que c'est assez drôle étant donné
que cette constitution il va très
exactement l'étrangler dans les heures
qui vont suivre leur il prête serment
et puis il prononce un disque alors ce
sont quelques paroles à l'emporte-pièce
il dit qu'il est à la disposition de la
république que il contre son sabre etc
est le garant de la paix publique que on
peut compter sur lui et le ton est assez
insolite dans cette enceinte parce qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude d'entendre ce ton
tranchant c'est ces paroles rapine et
quand il s'en va bien certains se
regardent en disant mais qu'est ce qu'on
a fait merrigan l'a fait c'est trop tard
alors maintenant il faut pour que le
décret de transfert des deux conseils
soient valables que le président du
directoire le sel et le promulgue alors
on va envoyer à griller des messages et
en lui demandant de venir gohier qui est
évidemment dans une situation très
difficile parce que le matin en se
réveillant il a entendu du bruit ou
plutôt c'est le bruit qui l'a réveillé
et a regardé par la fenêtre il a vu le
son armée parce que le directoire avait
une garde l'a gardée des accords qui
s'en allait qu'est ce qu'elle allait
faire de la laisse mettre à la
disposition de beaune a pas alors il n'y
avait plus de garde
il a appelé ses collègues il a appris qu
sieyès était urgent et du coc était déjà
parti pour les tuileries que bara
c'était dans son bain et refusait
obstinément d'en sortir barras qui se
disaient oh là là ne nous mouillons pas
on va bien voir ce qui va se passer
alors il restait que le pauvre moulin
qui est venu et ils ont délibéré tous
les deux à ce moment là on est venu les
trouver en disant tenez et pourquoi pas
ils sont partis pour les tueries arrive
et huileries au premier étage il trouve
bonaparte délibérant avec tous les
ministres ils sont tous là les ministres
y sont ralliés à beaune a pas alors on
diagou y écouter sieyès et roger du coc
ont démissionné barras va démissionner
démissionner encore démissionné aussi
goyer accepté de promulguer de sceller
la le décret des anciens comme ça le
transfert à sa cause est une affaire
réglée mais il veut pas des messieurs
nous disons qu'on peut s'amuser de
gaullier certains historiens se sont
amusés lui mais moi il me touche parce
qu'au milieu de cet abandon général
de ces gens qui ne pensent calme de ces
gens qui sont mus uniquement par
l'ambition magouilles et qui est
accroché à la constitution qui dit mais
non j'ai pas loin j'ai prêté serment
je peux pas faire ça bon c'est quand
même touchant alors moulin calque très
exactement son comportement sur celui
gouailleur leur bout d'un moment on ne
sait plus quoi en faire on ne décide de
les renvoyer au luxembourg avec une
bonne escorte
et là on voit les enfermer dans leur
département sous la garde de mort
horrible à wil général mauro qui devient
gardien de prison pendant quelques
heures
et voilà comment la journée à passer
comment elle s'est achevée disant
qu'elle a parfaitement réussi
mais que tout le monde sait parfaitement
aussi que les difficultés
c'est demain qu'elles commenceront alors
voyez vous il ya une légende est une
légende qui veut que
le 18 brumaire est était un coup d'état
techniquement réussie oui c'est ma
l'appart qui a parlé des techniques de
coup d'état
oui là on dit techniquement c'est très
bien mais non c'est pas très bien le
coup d'état du 19 rue mère est quelque
chose de très mal préparée et quelque
chose qui a failli échouer par la faute
de ceux qui l'on préparait tout
simplement et c'est ce que vous allez
voir c'est ce que nous allons voir
ensemble en étudiant maintenant la
journée du 19 rue mais le 19
la pluie qui est tombée toute la nuit
cesse au matin mais il reste beaucoup
d'humidité pile fait froid et pourtant
depuis les premières heures de la
matinée à travers le bois de boulogne
une file ininterrompue de cabriolets de
voitures de cavaliers se dirige vers ça
il faut traverser le bois pour aller à
saint cloud et ses voitures partent pour
saint cloud et il y à là dedans des
députés des représentants aux anciens
des représentants aux cinq sens et puis
aussi des les curieux des gens qui
veulent voir et puis aussi beaucoup de
militaires parce que cette file de
voitures et sans arrêt dépassé par des
escadrons montée des dragons des
cavaliers des chasseurs et ses députés
se disent mais pour
attends de tromper oui beaucoup de
troupes qui marchent vers saint cloud et
maintenant voilà que ces voitures des
bouches après avoir pris le pont
emprunté le pont de saint cloud et
tournez à gauche mais voilà dans le
château le château ne cherchait pas
n'existe plus le château de saint-cloud
il avait été construit par monsieur
frère du roi louis xiv par philippe
d'orléans et il a été brûlé en 1870 par
les prussiens de sorte qu'il n'y a plus
de traces mais dites vous bien que quand
vous prenez le tunnel de l'autoroute
eh bien c'est exactement au dessus à
votre goût c'était là qu'était le
château de saint cloud
très belle construction avec à
l'intérieur il avait aidé meublé mais à
l'intérieur subsister toutes ses
décorations d'or dont le 17e siècle
avait parsemé ses demeures alors ils
sont là dans les cours ils ne peuvent
pas siéger pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'on travaille toujours dans le
palais alors il ya deux salles dans
lesquelles on leva placé les deux
conseils on appris dans le château la
plus grande salle qui est la galerie
d'apollon et pour les 500 sacs à la
grande salle la galerie d'apollon c'est
pour les anciens et pour les 500 eh bien
on s'est installé dans on va les
installer dans l'orangerie l'orangerie
qui est toute une aile qui n'est pas
dans le château elle même mais qui
prolonge la galerie d'apollon vers les
jambes et dans ses deux salles et bien
il ya des ouvriers qui ont travaillé
d'ailleurs toute la nuit qui continue à
travailler pour installer parce que vous
savez c'était des salles vides et pour y
faire des assemblées parlementaires il
fallait faire quelque chose alors il
fallait construire des tribunes il
fallait installer des gradins il fallait
mettre des banques est il fallait le
drapé les murs des tos et pendant toute
cette matinée du 19 10 mère iliad et
d'oublier pixid
qui plante des plots des ouvriers qui
donne des coups de marteau et les
représentants eux sont dans la rue et ça
c'est laid c'est la très grave parce que
si ces gens là étaient descendus
directement de leur voiture pour passer
alors salle de réunion n'aurait pas eu
le temps de se consulter ben ça pendant
des heures car ça va durer toute la
matinée jusqu'au début d'après midi me
sont là désoeuvrés ils se parlent mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait là qu'est ce que
c'est que ce décret des anciens disaient
500 et pia les anciens qu'il y ait des
vous n'avez pas été convoquée la veille
et qu'ils disent mais enfin pourquoi
nous at on pas convaincu qu'est ce que
ça cache alors la foule continue à
arriver
remarque talent qui descend de sa
voiture
et puis on remarque aussi talent qui
n'avait ça ça a été la dernière
opération du 18 brumaire de la journée
du 18 brumaire talent qui est allé
porter qui est allé porter à barras la
lettre de démission qu'il avait rédigée
barras la signer cette lettre de
démission sans changer un mot sans
changer une virgule
il faut dire que d'après des traditions
qui semble avoir vraiment des fondements
sérieux talent n'apportez pas que la
lettre de démission mais beaucoup
d'argent ne faut pas oublier que autour
de ce coup d'état il ya les sommes
d'argent
kolo barst exemple colo le fournisseur
ouvrard le banquier se sont offerts dès
le départ ils ont apporté des fonds ces
fonds n'en disposent alors ces fonds
pourquoi ne pas jeter barrages qu'on
sait particulièrement vénale et barras
est parti le 18 brumaire vers son
château de grosbois pour punir entrer
dans l'obscurité
de sorte que maintenant on a vraiment
trois démissions de directeur oui voilà
talent qui arrivent là le 19 en
claudiquant dans la salle avec regret et
puis voilà
sieyès et roger du coc qui descendent
d'un cabriolet avec la garde le
secrétaire du directoire viola benjamin
constant qui aborde les uns les autres
et qui critiquent déjà la proclamation
de bonaparte et puis voilà tout à coup
un grand bruit une voiture entourée de
dragons et de chasseurs qui entre dans
la cour un homme en descend
précipitamment ses bonaparte bonaparte
qui va monter tout de suite dans les
appartements d'une première étape
et pendant ce temps les députés les
anciens les 500 par le toujours et se
disent mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire et
il y a au 500 en sorte
j'allais dire majorité non minorité de
jacobins cap elle plonge la pub à cette
époque là il n'ya sûr il n'y a plus de
club des jacobins
mais on les appelle jacobins parce que
c'est la gauche ne représente la
tendance de gauche et d'extrême gauche
de l'assemblée
autrefois il aurait été déjà coeur et or
ces gens là sont hérissés ils sentent
que ce d'affaires qui se prépare c'est
contre eux c'est contre la tendance
qu'il représente alors il paie n'a pas
retenu leurs collègues et digne mais
enfin nous n'allons pas laisser
étrangler la république qu'est ce que
c'est que ce tyran et quand bonaparte
est passé l'un d'eux a osé dire à haute
et intelligible voix
à bas les dictateurs alors on s'est
égayée dans les guinguettes dans les
auberges de saint cloud pour déjeuner on
continue à parler midi la salle n'est
pas prête 12h30 elle n'est pas prête une
heure elle n'est pas prête
enfin ça y est on peut sur alors
imaginez ces hommes ils sont vêtus de
toges de ressasser la tenue de l'époque
nous avait une époque assez étrange
finalement
la désigne forme si nous sommes bariolés
pour çà a été dessinée david est pour
quelque chose
et alors ils sont habillés d'une grande
offre où ils ont une toque sur la tête
épisode grande écharpe d'or et à lens
l'imaginé tous ces gens tous ces hommes
rouges qui rentre dans la salle qui
s'installe mais il installe dans un très
mauvais état d'esprit et le bruit qu'ils
font en entrant dans la salle prouve que
l'atmosphère est survoltée c'est alors
que vient s'asseoir au fauteuil de la
présidence
le président des cinq sens et il
s'appelle lucien bonheur
lucien bonaparte
ça me bouquet l'agila au 19 brumaire 24
ans c'est comme si vous aviez
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale à la
place de monsieur edgar faure un
président de 24 ans c'est quelque chose
que nous n'arrivons pas à comprendre
c'est ainsi à cette époque là je répète
que bonaparte à 30,1 il a 24 ans et
depuis l'origine et bien il s'est jeté
dans la révolution
ajaccio où il était à la société
populaire révolutionnaire il est parti
il est passé sur le continent il a été
dénoncé dans les clubs
paoli et si paoli a été décrétée
d'accusation c'est parce que ce petit
lucien bonaparte l'avait dénoncé ensuite
il passe à saint maximin devient
président de la société populaire alors
qu'il n'a pas plus guère plus de 20 ans
et alors là il
il obtient un certain nombre de deux
succès c'est ainsi qu'il change le nom
saint maximin en marathon et que lui il
change de prénom il n'est plus le sien
il est brutus
il épouse en même temps la soeur de son
de son aubergiste c'est qu'elle
s'appelle catherine boyer n'y a qu'un
ennui c'est qu'elle le sait ni lire ni
écrire pas même signer son nom il est
plongé à fond dans la révolution arrive
thermidor il est bien sûr arrêté et
c'est napoléon qui obtient sa libération
et pensons bien et tout ça ne s'explique
que si on pense à cette famille corse
étroitement unis c'est pas une famille
c'est un clan unis autour de la vieille
madre qui n'est pas si vieille que ça
cette époque là il s'appelle laetitia et
se tiennent les coudes et ils cèdent les
uns les autres
alors la napoléon vienne sauver lucie m
lui
et tous prêts à consacrer sa vie à
napoléon lors il est commissaire des
guerres il faut bien lui trouver un
métier il est à l'armée du rhin il est à
l'armée du nord et en veillant corsée
quand il est encore s'il a envie tout à
coup de presse se présenter à la
députation d'entrée aux cinq sens il n'a
pas l'âge il a 23 ans il en faut 25
tant pis se présente il était lui les
mêmes il est validé on n'est pas ça il
attend 3 mois avant de s'exprimer et
enfin beau jour il prend la parole aux
cinq sens et tout à coup ils écoutent ce
jeu là on écoute parce qu'il a le don de
la parole parce qu'il a appris
d'ailleurs à parler en public dans tous
ses clubs révolutionne l on l'écouté
mais mon l'élite secrétaire du
directoire et pendant que napoléon est
en egypte et bien barras dit joseph et
lucien ont gardé les avenues pour hbo
n'a pas c'est bien ce qu'il fait et
quand il est question du coup d'état il
est là n'oubliez pas que c'est lui qui a
présenté sieyès à bonnat pas ilena et en
même temps il sait que la présidence des
500 sera quelque chose d'essentiel lors
du coup d'état et pour bru maire il se
présente et il est élu à l'époque les
500 ne pense nullement qu'il va y avoir
un coup d'état
et voilà pourquoi une raison qui n'est
pas du tout un hasard au 19 brumaire
c'est lucien bonaparte qui vient
s'asseoir dans le fauteuil de la
présidence alors tout de suite quelqu'un
demande la parole c'est gaudin qui fait
taire les rumeurs et qui propose la
nomination d'une commission d' enquête
sur les dangers que court la république
ça ça fait partie du plan on s'est dit
que si on la même commission
on pourra agir plus facilement sur cinq
ou dix membres que sur 500 et alors on
obtiendra de cette commission la
proposition d'une sorte d' abdication
des 500 qui remettront aux anciens le
droit de nommer un nouveau gouvernement
mais voilà il vous savez ces députés ont
traversé toute la révolution pour la
plupart ils sont pas de la dernière
pluie ils savent exactement ce qu'il en
est et comprennent qu'on veut les
le ray avec cette commission il refuse d
voici faire entrer non pas de commission
le tumulte est énorme tout le monde est
debout en crillon et lucien essaye de se
faire entendre il n'y parvient pas
l'hyper vient mal on crie pas de
dictateur il avoue vouloir dire que son
frère n'est pas un dictateur
on crée pas de dictateur et il y à laleu
le colosse destrem qui est là qu est un
géant et qui dit regardez j'ai encore ma
tête sur les épaules
voilà que cette assemblée entièrement
dominée par l'opinion jacobine le centre
ce qu'on appelait autrefois le marais ce
tales n'ose même pas dire un mot et
voilà que delbrel un autre 500 à l'autre
membre des 500 se précipite à la tribune
et dit je demande puisque la
constitution est en danger que chacun de
nous chacun d'entre nous prêtent serment
à la constitution et ont la classe et
lucien est d'accord c'est curieux
pourquoi est il d'accord prêté serment à
la constitution alors qu'on ait la peau
en changer c'est que c'est un tacticien
lucien il sait parfaitement que pendant
que chacun viendra la tribune jury se
passera du temps et pendant ce temps là
on agira sur les anciens du moins il
l'espère et voilà le que la rom la
longue color cohorte des membres des 500
vient à la tribune je jure fidélité à la
constitution ça dure on les appelle
nominalement
ça prend du temps c'est exactement ce
que voulait lucien mais les anciens
vient les anciens prix c'est en eux
aussi dans leur salle de leur galerie
d'apollon et là ce sont des sommes
beaucoup plus posé les anciens
d'abord ils sont plus âgés de par la
constitution et puis ensuite l'habitude
et de délibéré dans le calme alors il
n'y a pas ce broyat passes-tu mur y'a
pas ce tintamarre
mais enfin il ya un malaise et dès le
départ certains viennent parler et dire
pourquoi ne m'attends pas convoqué hier
alors on explique l'ons explique mal et
on attend que quelqu'un fasse des
propositions bien personne n'en fait et
c'est là où se vérifie ce que je vous
dise
d'alleurs que ce conte et a été
singulièrement balboa de paris enfin on
n'a pas de scénario on sait pas ce qu'on
va demander aux anciens il n'ya pas des
drôles qui ont été distribués non rien
du tout alors ils parlent entre eux et
le malaise augmente
rien ne se dessine rien ne sait ce qui
ce même et ça dure une demi-heure 1h
1h30 2h 2h30 3h bientôt et le malaise
est de plus en plus grands et là haut au
premier étage bonaparte à l'appart à
temps je crois que nous pouvons imaginer
la tante de cet homme nous savons c'est
qu'elle vit l intense et en luynes
c'est l'impatience vue-là par ilna il se
ronge les ongles
il a des boutons sur le visage les
arrache le sang coule et les heures qui
passent et rien ne se réalisent et tout
à coup il prend la décision
il descend et avec quelques officines
entre avec son frère joseph avec berthe
il entre dans la langue celle des
anciens la salle qui le ventre et se
tait et tout à coup il prend la part il
pas or il n'a rien préparé
émile ollivier disait au 19e siècle il
ya eu trois grands improvisateurs
c'était monsieur berrier c'était
monsieur pierre et c'était moi nous
n'improvise y ont jamais bien sûr dans
une telle opération tous les maux kong
pis tu sais pas parler en public il sait
pas ce qu'il dit et alors ils accumulent
les lapsus il passe d'une idée à l'autre
les phrases non pas de terminaison n'ont
pas de conclusion c'est quelque chose
c'est qu'ils défient l'imagination c'est
c'est un homme qui perd pied
il parle il parle et on ne sait même pas
ce qu'il veut venir et on ne sait même
pas où il va on ne sait pas et ces
hommes qui sont habitués au beau langage
à la roja
ouah eh bien ces hommes là sont atterrés
quand il a fini mais il s'en va mais les
récits du temps nous disent que c'est
dans un grand et terrible silence il
centre quand il sort des anciens de la
salle des anciens il a fait un très
grand calme nous savons bien que ce
n'est pas vrai qu'il n'est pas calme
quelque chose qui bouillonne
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire quelque
chose de fou
il quitte les anciens pour passer à
l'orangerie celle et ça ça enfin ils
savaient ils avaient des rapports depuis
une heure de l'après midi qu'il y avait
insurrection parmi les 500 alors qu'il
avait été si inférieur devant les
anciens qui l'accueillît courtoisement
est ce qu ils pensaient qu'ils allaient
pouvoir venir à bout des cinq sens et il
entre entouré de quelques grenadiers il
ya une telle bousculade
plus personne n'est à sa place tout le
monde à seilh la tribune on l'a vient de
finir de voter on vient de finir de
prêter le serment tout le monde à saïx
la tribune et lucien ne sait plus que
faire ne sait plus que 10 il attend
éperdument le décret sauveur des anciens
la porte s'ouvre et se dit voilà lé
décret et ses bons appartient et il ya
une telle bousculade un tel tintamarre
que d'abord on ne le voit pas il est
obligé de se frayer le chemin à travers
les rangs il arrive sous la tribune et
alors on le reconnaît bon à part
immédiatement c'est un cri immense à bas
le dictateur point de dictateurs point
de dictateur et on le pressent de toutes
parts et on le bouscule
et quelqu'un essaie delbrel c'est
destrem plutôt py qui arrive qui donne
des coups de poing les grenadiers par
les coups de poing il est là il sait
plus où il en est il ferme les yeux
un nuage de sang devant les yeux il des
failles on l'emportent à peu près va
nous y est le cri le cric terrible et
pousser hors la loi le cri est repris
hors la loi
hors la loi hors la loi on l'a écrit
hors-la-loi le jour baisse pierre o 9
thermidor a été assailli rbds et spir a
porté sa tête à l'échafaud alors là on
la loi si on vote le hors-la-loi la
mainlevée tout simplement et bien
bonaparte on peut mettre contre amir le
fusil et sur le champ sans jugement hors
la loi et aussi en reste seul avec la
meute et il demande le coup la parole il
l'a laissez moi parler laissez moi
parler je demande la parole
mais quand même une a l'air si bouillant
désir il si fort parler que les autres
subissent ont l'ascendant et et se
taisent un instant il dit vous ne deviez
pas cueillir le général bonaparte comme
ça vous ne savez pas ce qu'il voulait il
voulait peut-être vous faire un rapport
sur les affaires de la radio les filles
dit quelqu'un bonaparte a terni sa
gloire aujourd'hui point du dictateur au
la loi et tout le monde en la loi hors
la loi et les cris les insultes
on propose une motion la vente on ne
peut pas compter le nombre des voix on
ne sait plus où on en est et alors les
siens tout à coup se dresse lui le
président ils enlèvent dans un geste
théâtral sa toque la dépose sur la
tribune enlève sa toge la dépose sur la
tribune enlève son écharpe d'or la
dépose sur la tribune hélas le devant le
silence qui s'était établi il dit devant
le mouvement inconvenant qui vient de
s'établir ici je relance je dépose en
signe de deuil
sur cette tribune mais un signe
populaire quelques instants avant il
s'était adressé un général qui était
entrée dvi i phone souhaité arranger les
choses il faut balayer l'assemblée
générale entre avec des soldats en
reprend lucien e.on l'emportent comme on
avait fait de bonnes à part et à la
porte de la sambre il trouve un cheval
sur lequel il saute et bonaparte a
compris que vraiment le coup d'état
avait échoué et que maintenant il
fallait utiliser la force est fort ce
qu'on avait voulu éviter
utilisez alors on a décidé de faire
donner la troupe
mais attention c'est qu'il y a une garde
des conseils
elle est là aux portes d un sens aux
portes des anciens cette garde et forte
de nombreux hommes ils sont bien armés
et ces gens là sont fidèles aux conseils
et ces gens là ne sont pas décidés à
marcher contre les conseils alors est-ce
que les autres est ce que les soldats
vont marcher contre les conseils et ce
qu'il vient voir des soldats français
contre des soldats français ce qu'on va
s'entretuer est-ce qu enfin les premiers
vont accepter de tirer sur les seconds
on sait pas et cela ne l'a pas lucien
bonhomme est littéralement le sauveur
parce qu'il est le président lui des
cinq sens et les sur son chevalet il
s'adresse aux gardes des conseils leur
dit c'est le président des 500 qui vous
parle il y actuellement une minorité
d'assassins au sein des 500 les
représentant à stylet qui sont en train
de prendre la domination de la manse
majorité qui ne veut pas cela et il
déclare ce ne sont plus des
représentants du peuple
ce sont des représentants du poignard et
il faut marcher sur ces gens là et oui
et comme ses gardes des conseils ont le
sens de la légalité ils ont l'impression
que la légalité vient de leur parler ou
bien chercher peut-être un alibi aussi
bas ils l'ont trouvée et en même temps
lucien bonaparte rend son épée la pause
sur la poitrine de son frère napoléon et
jure de percer ce saint
si jamais il y sentez battre le coeur
d'un tyran tout ça ça c'est très bien
et maintenant voilà que les gardes du
conseil sont littéralement électrisé
comme les autres trous et voilà que
murat et leclerc les entraîne et voilà
que les tambours bat c'est la charge
l'on pénètre dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée des cinq sens un officier
cris citoyens vous êtes dissous mais
murat lui murat hurle foutez moi tout
ces gens là dehors alors il s'enfuit
genthod ge rouge les hommes rougissant
fille cherche partout on ouvre les
fenêtres on saute par la fenêtre on
s'éparpille dans le parc on s'en fiche
on laisse les toges rouges quelquefois
accrochés à des buissons sans fillon
sens
puis on s'en tenir jusqu'au village de
saint cloud en se cache le coup d'état
alors le soir dans la nuit on essaiera
de récupérer dans les auberges les
guinguettes de 5 ou des députés alors on
en trouvera quelques dizaines on les
fera venir le tout est plongé dans la
nuit la salle et dans la nuit il ya au
mur des lampes à huile et là dans la
pénombre et bien on lit rapidement un
projet de décision
les 500 now ma nouveau gouvernement un
gouvernement provisoire de trois consuls
les trois consuls seront bas la partié
yes déroger du co c'est fini et le soir
à 3 heures du matin seulement bonaparte
montera dans sa voiture pour regagner
paris
il est épuisé littéralement il est avec
bourienne ndi pam au point tout le
trajet pas un pas un an
c'est seulement quand il est arrivé rue
de la victoire que rentrer chez lui
bourienne l'accompagné toujours se
tourner vers brienne et lydia là j'ai
dit beaucoup de bêtises pas mal mon
général ce sens et bourgaud d'avocats il
m'en est timide et je suis pas habituée
aux assemblées cela viendra et cela est
venu en effet
[Musique]